about khloe kardashian's new face yo you
seen this [ __ ]
I don't know why we're like surprised at
kardashian surgery
he says buddy understand why that this
is news every single time they get
surgery they get carved up that's what
they do why is this it's just shocking
at first it's like Facebook updates
remember way back in the day when
Facebook would change everything and you
be like what the [ __ ] is this and then
you get used to it and like that and
then we change the next time like what
the [ __ ] is this the new operating so
you hate initially but then you're like
no that was the right thing to do yeah
and it was like it looks like Denise
Richards yeah a little bit a little bit
I mean she looks undeniably better like
this I think we have to talk about with
plastic surgery with women right they
have the ability especially these girls
right they I mean like their job is to
be attractive and have a cool life right
yeah was it it didn't start that way
hard job was to be the funny fat which
would be the funny fat friend right and
then but reality is a lot of like women
that don't have like a skill in
entertainment their job is have a cool
lifestyle and be attractive yeah right
and the cool of the lifestyle and the
more attractive the more followers they
get and then the more money they make
right because they'll get different
sponsorship opportunities they want to
be brand ambassadors for these other
companies etc so it completely believes
them to invest in how they look if that
means carving up their [ __ ] face it
actually makes sense matter of fact any
girl who wants to be an entertainment
that doesn't carve up their face it's
kind of a [ __ ] idiot it's like a
basketball player that doesn't exercise
it's like hey you could jog more and
then have your legs in the you know in
the fourth quarter and then be able to
score more points and you could
potentially win or you could not in
choosing not to to be natural it's
almost like you're a [ __ ] idiot in
their field like if you're gonna be a
cyclist you got to use EPO if you're
gonna be cyclists you've got a dope you
cannot win without doping even now they
try to clean up the sport you got a dope
that's the name of the game if you're a
weightlifter you got to use steroids
everybody
uses it paying college players if you
want if you want to be successful
college basketball team nine coaches pay
players and the others in last place
that's the same sit that's pervy right
so it's like of course they're gonna do
it and to be honest think about how
quick it is for a girl you get a surgery
on your face you get new tits you get
new ass you're spending such a small
amount of money to increase your value
in your world
imagine you or I could spend five
thousand dollars to be ten times funnier
ya 10x funny you think men wouldn't
invest in that you're out of your
[ __ ] mind
yeah valid 10x funny yeah I do think it
looks a little weird like the amount of
her face that's missing is crazy like
how much of her face is it cuz she took
out all the oj from her face but but
realistically that was the part that
should have gone he finally looks like
Caitlyn's daughter yeah she definitely
looks more like a Kardashian you think
the surgeon what Oh J and Caitlin and
linen clothes oh yeah I think they just
got one for the fam I mean all this the
teeth everything is done but she looks
undeniably better you can't deny it
yeah it still looks weird my god you see
ambition looks like so fake that it's
weird so here's the thing I'm with my
line as much earlier than most dudes I'm
starting to realize but I'm with you on
this yeah they look weird yeah but
here's the question we need to ask
ourselves is weird better than ugly hmm
it's not is weird better than hot
because they weren't hot is weird better
than ugly and a lot of times these girls
morph their face so they become weird
but the weird is actually more
attractive than they were so they'll
take the looks because at least they're
getting looks I think the issue with
that though is a you're neglecting that
there's no negative side effects from
plastic surgery
no I mean you could have like you aged
weird or like it costs money you have to
like keep touching it up over like they
all aged nerve loss or like yeah like
paralysis like house last two senses
were very funny
you're a neglect negative side effect
there are none no I mean what you're
saying what you say might be true but
like let's be honest like I don't think
a Kardashian is gonna get her face
paralyzed like probably not and in terms
of like aging weird they're gonna do
this as they women just get plastic
surgery as they get old now this is the
new normal
like if you have enough money to afford
it you get it I don't think there's one
woman that is aging naturally that is
under sixty years old now can we name
one who's just like [ __ ] I'm gonna
name a generic actual going under
cutting up face or you tell my like
Botox Botox included but yeah easy how
we like separate that like yeah how
craziest active right now we're going
wow is just Botox there was a time where
you got Botox it was like oh right right
you're you're injecting a [ __ ] poison
into your face that freezes your skin
and now that's like it's just Botox yeah
dude they're guys that do Botox we know
one of the guys we went out that we were
down at [ __ ] Arizona oh my god I just
texted him the other day
Arizona girls yeah the Arizona guy oh my
god I just took my dad I know you're
listening I forgot your name my bad but
um
Tyler but and basically he was doing
Botox for dudes dude remember that guy's
name so yeah I think he's happy you know
but his business is flourishing because
of it but in that crate like that's just
normal like all of our girlfriends right
now are gonna expect to get talks
hundred percent you could act like your
girls not I would put $100,000 on the
stagnant gonna get it I'm not hanging
that bet to me the line is like
invasiveness I guess like if it's your
[ __ ] cutting things and I was Botox
makes you a little uncomfortable cause
it's an injection but it's different
when a surgery oh so here's the thing
the better the surgery gets the less
invasive it gets remember back in the
day the nose job was you chop away at
the nose and hack away and all [ __ ] now
you got this thing where they just
squeeze excuse me
they put filler the same I don't know if
it's the same filler they put in your
cheeks and that kind of stuff but they
put filler and they can reshape your
nose with filler so let's say you have
like a like a round nose yeah they
actually fill in the top part so it
looks like it's just going straight down
hmm
so all this [ __ ] is getting way better
obviously initially when plastic surgery
started I assume it started probably
after uh one of the wars this is my
assumption it probably happened after
one you have all these people they were
like super maimed from things that
happen in war and they're like trying to
carve you back to life that's what I'm
assuming
and then eventually paper like that kind
of works let me do that on this mmm it's
gonna evolve and it's gonna get so it's
gonna get so good that the procedure is
gonna be so minor why would I not get
that you know it's gonna end up so we
talked about like with genetic testing
or what a genetic modification you can
make like a super baby and we're always
gonna have these babies that have the
perfect genes yeah we're just gonna be
able to do that retroactively a surgery
it seems like yeah like we can yeah
you're already born and that technology
doesn't exist to do it before but yeah
well you get surgery look however you
want to look yeah and should you should
you maximize your life yeah and it's
also in a sense so it's gonna be like
well then what we're all just gonna end
up looking great and looking the same
and then what's and there is like level
[ __ ] out we'll find somebody you know
some other way to create a hierarchy but
it is interesting that you've got all
these naturally pretty [ __ ] like
[ __ ] Alicia Keys going well let's be
natural it's like [ __ ] you look good
natural yeah not everybody looks good
natural everybody looks good I'll make
up the other man it's like it's like
LeBron literally going you know guys we
should just you know stop lifting
weights or Zion gone why are we doing
this [ __ ] why are we putting so much
effort into our bodies it's like yeah
you won the [ __ ] lottery you're it's
no different than like white people
saying yeah they're just a beta law it's
like white people you get to yell at the
cops as a white guy nobody's gonna kill
you when you yell at the cops not
everybody else gets to do that have one
I can't argue with weightlifting and
[ __ ] though to Mark's point there's
positive side effects only to
weightlifting now my guys start using
steroids and there's negative side
effects with it then we start looking at
it like brown or if you should do that
no you can still get hurt if you wait
lift the wrong way but generally
speaking it's much better for you to
wait lift and not wait lift like if two
people are living their lives you would
say
man lift weights true you're not gonna
say two people living their lives it's
much healthier for you to get plastic
surgery like head just for your body and
your soul in your mind and all that [ __ ]
all I'm saying is when when hot chicks
preach this natural [ __ ] they're doing
it because it benefits them they're like
yeah I'm the hottest of the hot
so let's maintain this hierarchy so I
don't have to do anymore but if you're
an ugly chick you're like nah [ __ ]
I'm coming for you [ __ ] yeah why should
I live my life like this I wonder how
she feels when she looks in the mirror
now like she has a completely different
face like you looks like two separate
bathroom plastic surgeons all so scared
it's like something you grew up with
your entire life now you look in the
mirror and you see a different person
looking back at you that most and I
think that's where it goes where it is
though here's where it is I think that
women are so accustomed to how they look
on Instagram and on snapchat with the
filters that their mind has started to
morph to believe that's what they look
like I truly believe that the perception
of self I'm being a hundred percent
seriously no it's possible but in my
mind it logically it's like you look in
a mirror way more than you look at
yourself on your who would think no no
worry they're mirror is the floor mirror
is the phone they only look at the phone
they're mirror is the phone in there
[ __ ] you've got to go through the
process on your initial Instagram of
adding the filters right they're not so
the first thing you look at is you and
then you say okay I make myself to
lawyers I make myself filters are on
already like snapchat now that starts
the filters on it why are you looking at
the phone and also think about this way
why I'd be looking cute as [ __ ] honestly
that's why I think people use tick-tock
B's I think tick-tock morphs your face I
had some video that showed it but I
think tick-tock actually morphs your
face to make you look better looking so
of course you're going to spend more
time on this app that makes you look
better than you do at the hot take if
people don't know about the hot girl
showing it like she like caught the app
she kind of exposed that app in a weird
way but nobody's gonna care but that's
yeah of course it's brilliant makes
everybody better looking so now you're
looking at better looking people what
you have some facts no is
this is some other thing that happened
with like dressing rooms like where all
of a sudden there's a nicer mirrors like
they put slimming mirrors the best
lighting so you ever go to a grocery
store to fruit look mad good yeah and
the water on a fruit how the water boys
your house it looks natural is this all
over the place
[Applause]
you